[Music]
hello and welcome to in two minutes the
show that takes the biggest gaming
brouhaha of the week and dissect it and
boils it down into a handy digestible
two-minute chunk you could call us the
clown cart of informative web based
shows that's not just because I love
custard pying my colleagues in the face
yes mr. president
right away mr. president knowledge but
because we can fit a lot into a small
space this week it's call of duty
o'clock the release of House of Duty
advance card fair
I mean call of duty advanced warfare got
me thinking pal messed up with the world
be if everything in Call of Duty's
campaigns actually happened the first
three games focused on recreating
battles from World War two but from Call
of Duty 4 onwards they kind of turned
into a global and galactic free-for-all
so here's pals with who how many wrecked
cars are we gonna emerge groggily out of
this time and how many countries have
just been nuked well let's go from
Modern Warfare onwards because if we add
in handhelds and the free-to-play micro
transaction based first-person shooter
that's only available in China we'll be
here until the next game comes out so
I've got two minutes to run you through
the stories of seven Call of Duty games
well I do like a challenge
following actual World War two battles
like Stalingrad world war sets up the
scene for black ops or blopps 1 & 2 by
introducing sometimes real sometimes
ghosts Victor rain fire Rezanov plops
one takes place during the Cold War tell
us what you know why May I'm trying calm
down except in this cold war the Soviets
are using the numbers Mason yes those to
activate sleeper agents to release a
Nazi made biochemical weapon in the u.s.
lops 2 polishes off the Cold War saga by
chronicling the rise of a knocko
terrorist movement who aim to [ __ ]
the rich and give to the poor so like
Robin Hood but with nukes instead of
bows and arrows in 2025 the movement has
like a billion followers and sparks a
cold war between the US and China the US
drone fleet gets hacked and bombs la
steam guards not looking too dumb now is
it the game has multiple endings like
you can either end the war by getting
the US and China back together or you
could just jam with a vent
Sevenfold the big bad of the modern
warfare trilogy is Russian
ultra-nationalist Vladimir Makarov who's
hell-bent on bringing down the US over
the course of the games nukes almost
destroyed the US East Coast as a civil
war in Russia a nuclear blast in the
Middle East and that infamous airport
level which sparks a Russian invasion of
the u.s. modern warfare 3 concludes with
the American saving the Russian
president who sends all of his troops
home the bad guy gets taken out and
everyone is friends again
our accept soap dies ghosts takes place
in its own alternate timeline the
oil-rich Middle East gets destroyed and
a bunch of oil-producing South American
countries band together to form a new
global superpower called the Federation
who then hijack a space station and
destroy the American Southwest and weak
in the US both financially and with
explosions and only a bunch of stealthy
soldiers and a dog form they're ghosts
they help take down the Federation's
orbital bombardment system but one of
the team gets kidnapped and brainwashed
the numbers Logan what do they need
that's the wrong game so there we have
it the really messed up war-torn world
according to Call of Duty in just under
2 minutes I know I impress myself I'm
sure my parents are really proud so now
we come to advanced warfare another new
universe with more factions hell-bent on
destroying each other with invisible
helicopters exosuits and Troy Baker but
you know one of them is led by Kevin
Spacey so I guess I'm game join me next
week as I try to fit another impossibly
long and convoluted topic into a strict
time frame for your viewing pleasure
until then you can catch me on Twitter
at Lucy James games I'll see you next
time
you
[Music]